لذا فإن المعارضين الجمهوريين لدونالد
ترامب لديهم في الواقع أي فرصة حقيقية
لهزيمته في موسم الانتخابات التمهيدية هذا،
أعني أن متوسط ​​الرئيس السابق
شمال 50 بالمائة من استطلاعات الرأي التي تم إجراؤها
بعد أول لائحة اتهام له في مارس،
ولا يوجد مرشح وأكرر لا يوجد مرشح
في موقف ترامب  في صناديق الاقتراع في هذه
المرحلة، لم يخسر الترشيح على الإطلاق
خلال العصر التمهيدي الحديث، لكني
لاحظت ذلك ولكن لم يكن هناك سوى
مرشح واحد فقط في عام 2000 لم يكن
رئيسًا في منصبه ولم يخسر
ولاية تمهيدية واحدة على الأقل أثناء
الترشيح  معالجة ما أفهمه يا
رفاق هو أنه من النادر جدًا أن يتم
التتويج.
أصبح ترامب في النهاية مرشح الحزب الجمهوري،
ومن المحتمل أن يتعرق
قليلاً على الأقل خلال
موسم الانتخابات التمهيدية، وفي الواقع قد تكون قاعدة ترامب في
ماغا أصغر قليلاً مما قد تكون عليه.  تخيل أنه في
مكان ما شمال حوالي
ثلث الحزب فقط سوف يتمسك
بترامب بغض النظر عن
قاعدته، وقد رأينا ذلك في استطلاعات الرأي خلال
الموسم التمهيدي بأكمله ولكن هناك
ربعًا آخر من الحزب لن
يتراجع.  بغض النظر عن ترامب، في
هذه المرحلة، يمكنك دمج نسبة 25%
مع 37% من
الناخبين الأساسيين الذين يمكن إقناعهم، هؤلاء الأشخاص
منفتحون على دعم ترامب ولكنهم لم
يقرروا بعد ولديك صيغة
للتغلب عليه وهي أغلبية
الحزب الذي لا يحب
الرئيس السابق تمامًا
توحيد هذين الفصيلين خلف
مرشح واحد لن يكون سهلاً لأن
حقيقة الأمر هي أن الأشخاص الذين يمكن
إقناعهم مثل ترامب في حين أن أولئك غير
المنفتحين عليه ببساطة لا يفعلون ذلك ولكن هناك
هناك بعض أوجه التشابه بين
المجموعتين، في حين أن 57 من قاعدة البيانات يطلقون على
أنفسهم اسم المحافظين للغاية الذين يمكن إقناعهم،
وأولئك الذين ليسوا منفتحين على ترامب
هم أقل عرضة بكثير لاعتبار
أنفسهم محافظين للغاية
بالفعل من الأشخاص الذين أجابوا على
سؤال الاستطلاع هذا، وقال 34 من قاعدة البيانات
إنهم قدموا  أقل من خمسين ألف دولار
سنويًا بينما من
المرجح أن تكون المجموعتان الأخريان أفضل حالًا ماليًا،
وهذا يشير إلى أنه إذا كان ترامب
سيخسر، فربما تكون ولاية نيو هامبشاير هي أفضل مكان للبدء، وهي
ولاية الجرانيت
التي تعد الأكثر اعتدالًا والأغنى في الولايات المتحدة.
لن يكون الأمر سهلاً في الولايات المتحدة التمهيدية المبكرة، لكنني
تعلمت شيئًا قيمًا خلال
عهد ترامب لا تقل أبدًا شيئًا
أجنبيًا